that's me breathing on the noodles today
we're gonna try chopstick gadget I'm
pretty decent like I was never the
person who asked for for Chinese takeout
was probably like my first experience
and so that looks like probably a middle
grade school chopsticks are just so fun
because it's utensil that's very easy to
pick up and use I can kind of filter the
chopsticks pretty well and like I know I
feel like such a noob there's different
chopsticks oh yeah the Japanese ones
will be like shorter and poignant
Chinese ones are a little more like even
from tip to the hello yeah yeah yeah
there's also a finesse it's like your
fingers are dancing around while you
like pick things up oh it is very
elegant
I hate chopsticks knobs you're holding
it wrong there's only one right way to
hold it honestly if people are trying
and they're trying to learn mine in my
book if you can get the food in your
mouth I'm happy for you
I left booze I want to start using that
little booze chopsticks are finished now
they are I have no idea what chopstick
gadget means so maybe it's just to make
your chopstick experience better
shall we try some chopstick gadgets
let's do it let's start yeah beat me I
knew I smelled it these are super cute
how I have no idea how to use it oh yeah
I know this is more confusing what do
you put in here oh wait look yes when
you're totally it's essentially like
forcing your hand into the CRO okay this
is smart is this real like children I
feel like my fingers are too chunky oh
okay okay
ah yes and the what's called a watchin
play on drafting walking over to the
kimchi tree what is the giraffe noise do
it's a little awkward for me but it
still works
oh it was doing the whole like crossing
thing you know the slipperiness though I
will say I feel like I bear better with
using my fingers I personally feel like
these restrict the movement too much yes
like you can take one part off and maybe
like oh they're more advanced or you can
take this part off and be like they're
just chopsticks
it just got level two let's try the next
ride no what the hell huh oh my god it's
a chopstick fork Wow one side is not
really chopsticks more like tweezers a
fork stick fruits or at a chop fork they
reminds me of like they've liked the
sport someone who is like I'm interested
in learning about the culture but also
my tongue yeah I feel like I'm holding
it like firing the fork works fire get
rid of every other utensils yeah I don't
even need spoons and you know this is
great for twirling but it as would the
other end with the forks again the range
of motion is not yeah you know you you
want to spread as wide as you want and
close when you want to close what are
instances though where I'm like I need
both a chopstick and also what are those
instances where there isn't both
available to you that are separate
entities best of both worlds now we have
to add there go oh my god wow oh my gosh
maybe I could wait
Grill oh my god incredible uh-huh what
way do you think it was before damn it
well what this is like I heard it likes
great thing the thing this is great
because like if this happens with your
friend oh here I'll help you out
oh oh oh wow this is so nice Joe can
enjoy the incredible oh can you break
them apart workout oh I'm gonna take a
wish that's mine please I want to even
be supple
ah wow this is like the Sebastian inside
Sebastian don't insert Sebastian are
these lightsabers wow this is okay I
would never eat this is all I ever do
always which one oh one yeah there we go
now that's cool anyway yeah this is
already cool
yeah the back end of the chopstick which
MIT cuz that's where the battery there
to girthy but yes they are ways of
Goethe's you know how people use
chopsticks as to like put their hair up
this would be a game changer you should
try it I hope you can eat chopsticks at
a rave with this Oh in the dark God a
rave chopstick party Oh see look at that
alright no one is I can make basically
crop this whole thing okay Wow yeah I
know off for some reason I feel like I'm
in the year 3000 I feel that too it does
its job don't you get it like people say
use the for clear he wasn't that good I
got it now yes they're all very fun
gadgets but I'm gonna be sticking to my
regular japanese-style chopsticks I will
probably not straight but come back to
these really remote
you might leave the room with me so then
I have both pairs
[Music]
you